the interest rate set by the bank of
England stands at 2.25 percent the
highest for 14 years more Rises are
coming though the bank of England's
Chief economists warming the market to
the idea of a significant rate rise in
the months ahead investors now forecast
it could hit four percent in November
peaking as you can see in the spring at
over six percent that's the highest rate
in two decades now that volatility has
left lenders scrambling to reprice their
mortgage deals on Friday morning as the
chancellor stood up and delivered his
mini budget there were over 3 900
Residential Mortgage deals on the market
now since then more than 1 600 have been
taken off 935 on Tuesday in a record one
day fall more than double the previous
drop at the start of the pandemic in
April 2020 and a further 321 in the last
24 hours to
2340. Now Products left on the market
and those new ones are becoming
increasingly more expensive in December
when the bank of England first started
hiking rates in response to the current
inflation crisis the average five-year
fixed mortgage was at 2.64 that has
almost doubled to 4.83 so an average
mortgage of 200 000 pounds costing 911
pounds a month last year for example
will now cost more than 1
149 pounds on average that's an extra
238 pounds a month now that's what's
about to happen to Alex due to
remortgage next year and considering
selling his house
it feels like you can't dream anymore in
you can't someone like me isn't allowed
to have a house like this anymore and
that seems to be that you know the way
it comes across that you know we've we
thought we could have some nice things
and it's like well no you can't because
you need to be super rich to be able to
do that and that seems daft
now also of concern among the biggest
fallers on the ftse 100 were
unsurprisingly house builders Barrett
developments a 12 drop Taylor wimpy and
persimmon both down six percent and
shares also down for the website
Rightmove more than seven percent now
the fear now is that as interest rates
rise inexorably the housing market edges
closer to a potential crash